coup c'est ducation récemment un
classement mondial a relégué les
universités françaises très loin des
meilleurs aujourd'hui c'est le
prestigieux journal britannique le
financial times qui a évalué les écoles
de commerce bonne nouvelle
les françaises occupent cette fois le
haut du classement elles sont sept parmi
les 10 meilleurs et hec occupe la
première place
nicolas lemarignier josé boulesteix h
ces trois lettres prestigieuse et une
filière d'excellence pour bon nombre de
ces étudiants venus à chaud c'est parce
que je savais je vais avoir une qualité
d'enseignement importante et aussi nous
très très bonnes manières toile emploi
après hec hacker fait simplement un vomi
dimension internationale et autres
paille
aujourd'hui c'est le financiel times qui
confirme le quotidien britannique publié
un classement des écoles de commerce
européennes hec est en tête
mieux encore cette école sur les dix
meilleurs sont françaises
au palmarès il y a aussi le scp de paris
l'essec l'edhec et cetera
mais qu'est ce qui explique cette
suprématie française
on a une très grande proximité avec le
monde de l'entreprise ça veut dire aussi
des élèves très bien sélectionner et
puis ça veut dire des élèves qui sont
formés dans un contexte international
avec des périodes en entreprise des
périodes en universités en france et
surtout à l'étranger
parmi les critères la rémunération les
débouchés la qualité des enseignements
trois ans après sa sortie de l'école un
diplômé d hec gagne douze mille euros de
plus par an qu'un diplômé de la london
school of economics
huitième au classement pour la mobilité
internationale les écoles de commerce
made in france trustent les premières
places en tête
l'école de lyon sur la troisième marche
le scp de paris pour ces raisons les
écoles de commerce françaises attire de
plus en plus d'élèves lors des salons
par exemple des étudiants français mais
pas seulement dans certains
établissements les étrangers
représentent un tiers des effectifs